as we near the four year anniversary of
the one october shooting many are
already gathering to honor the 60 we
lost a small vigil was held outside
silver state health tonight to remember
those victims it's a dark day that no
one will ever forget but the end of a
years-long lawsuit marks another step
towards healing sasha loftis joins us
live from the healing garden with more
tonight
denise and brian the pain of that day is
still fresh but the attorney i spoke
with tonight hopes that that settlement
will bring some relief after so much
suffering
it just changes your whole life jackie
barron shares her struggles since the
one october shooting the terror she
faced and the memories still cinched in
her mind all of a sudden it just started
popping and people started running she
says nothing can bring she and other
survivors peace
but as friday marks the fourth
anniversary of the route 91 harvest
festival many can breathe a sigh of
relief as an 800 million dollar lawsuit
settlement from mgm resorts draws to a
close it provides them closure you know
i'm not suggesting that it's something
that any of them will forget attorney
robert eglet represented many of the
more than 4 thousand victims and
relatives who received compensation he
says two court approved judges evaluated
claims and awarded money based on five
tears including ptsd physical injuries
or death with amounts starting at five
thousand dollars it's over we don't have
to go through protracted litigation for
years eglet and his team hope many can
find comfort at the end of this chapter
time does not get away from it but
barron hopes we always remember the day
the world changed for everyone in las
vegas
eglet's team tells me all of the clients
that were named in the settlement in
relation to their firm have gotten their
settlement money except for a few that
are still dealing with logistical issues
reporting live downtown tonight sasha
loftis live local now